في خامس ايام هذا التصعيد هكذا تبدو
الصوره الان في غزه كما تشاهدون طائرات
حربيه
ومسيره واصلت عبرها اسرائيل وغاراتها على
القطاع المحاصر غارات رفعت عدد الشهداء
الى 33 بينهم نساء واطفال وما يقارب 150
جريحه تتابع هذه التطورات مع مراسلين
ونبحث تداعياتها مع ضيوفنا على من غزه
الان مراسلنا وائل الدحدوح ومن عسقلان
مراسلنا الياس كرام اهلا بكما ابدا معك
وائل كيف هي غزه الان
غزه ما تزال في تعيش نفس الاجواء حقيقه من
التوتر والترقب والقلق والخوف ايضا
وتعيش نفس الاصوات ونفس التاثيرات جراءه
استمرار عمليات القصف واطلاق ايضا استمرار
اطلاق الرشقات الصاروخيه وان كانت بوتيره
اقل خلال الساعتين الماضيتين او الساعات
الثلاث الماضيه ان صح التعبير على وجه
الدقه ولكن قبل لحظات من الان
شاهدنا اطلاق رشقه من الصواريخ باتجاه
الاهداف الاسرائيليه وكما يبدو من شكل هذه
الصواريخ وطبيعه اندفاعها
يبدو انها تستهدف اهدافا في منطقه غلاف
قطاع غزه الواقعه على تخوم الحدود مع
القطاع من الناحيتين الشماليه والشرقيه
وهذه الرشقه كانت مؤلفه من عدد كبير من
الصواريخ
وشاهدنا ايضا ان القبه الحديديه حاولت
اعتراض هذه الرشقه ولكن لم نستمع او لم
نشاهد سوى قذيفتين صاروخيتين اطلقتها
القبه الحديديه بمعنى ان هناك اكثر من
اربعه صواريخ تمكنت بالفعل من تجاوز هذه
القبه وصواريخها ومنظومه دفاعها وايضا
الوصول الى الاهداف التي اطلقت باتجاهها
وعليه فان هذه الرشقه تدشن سلسله من
الرشقات التي اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
حتى الساعه السادسه من صباح هذا اليوم وان
كانت كما قلنا بوتيره
محدوده وعلى فترات متباعده وكما يبدو
بانها استهدفت اهدافا اسرائيليه في مناطق
الغلاف او تتجاوز في واحده منها بقليل حيث
استهدفت منطقه عسقلان كما اعلن من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الوجه الاخر من
الصوره بالتاكيد الغارات الاسرائيليه لم
تتوقف وان كانت تراجعت هي الاخرى على
الاقل من حيث نوعيه الاهداف التي
استهدفتها هذه الغارات لكن سياسه استمرار
استهداف المنازل استمرت حتى الساعات
الاولى من فجر هذا اليوم اخر المنازل التي
استهدفت بالغارات الاسرائيليه ودمرتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه كانت تلك
التي استهدفت منزلا في منطقه اليرموك وهي
منطقه ليست بعيده من المكان الذي نتواجد
فيه في قلب مدينه غزه هذا المنزل دمرته
بالكامل وبالتالي تحول الى كومه من الركام
وهو بالمناسبه لا يفصله كثير من الوقت عن
استهداف منزل والد الشهيد بهاء ابو العطا
احد القياديين البارزين لصرايا القدس
والذي اغتالته
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عام 2019
وبالتالي هذه سلسله المنازل وكانت
بالتاكيد خلال ساعات المساء قد استهدفت
ودمرت ايضا منزلين اخرين الاول في منطقه
حي الزيتون والثاني في منطقه دير البلح في
محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هناك
وبالتالي سلسله وسياسه استهداف المنازل ما
تزال مستمره لكن الساعات الماضيه او على
الاقل حتى ما قبل ساعتين من الان او ثلاث
ساعات كانت الاستهدافات او تركزت
الاستهدافات ضد اراضي زراعيه في منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه وشرق مدينه غزه ايضا وفي
قلب مدينه غزه بالتاكيد وفي المناطق
الجنوبيه حيث سجلنا او شاهدنا وتابعنا
سلسله من الغارات التي نفذت عن طريق
الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله واستهدفت هذه
الاراضي وعاده ما تقول قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انها ليست اراضي زراعيه وانما
اهداف تتبع لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لكن هذه المناطق بالتاكيد في منطقه كقطاع
غزه تعتبر ذات خطر على كل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين باعتبار ان هذه النوعيه التي
يطلق عليها اراضي زراعيه بحته تكون غير
موجوده وغير متوفره في قطاع غزه الا في
حدود ضيقه جدا جدا في القطاع فغالبيه
المناطق في قطاع غزه وهو الرقعه الجغرافيه
السهليه الصغيره يوجد فيها منازل
المواطنين يعني في على امتداد كل
المحافظات الخمس ولذلك ربما هذا ما يفسر
حجم الاضرار التي يعني
تصاب بها المنازل والبيوت في معظم عمليات
القصف ناهيك بطبيعه الحال عن القصف التي
تستهدف المنازل والشقق السكنيه
يعني في قلب المدن يبقى الحدث الابرز
حقيقه هو اغتيال القيادي في سرايا القدس
ومسؤول وحده العمليات فيها اياد الحسني
مساء امس في استهداف شقه سكنيه في بنايه
سكنيه في منطقه سكنيه بحي النصر الى الغرب
والى الشمال الغربي من مدينه غزه
وبالتالي بعد هذا الاستهداف بالتاكيد كانت
هناك رشقات صاروخيه لكن على الاقل حتى
الان لم نشاهد رشقات صاروخيه كتلك التي
تبعت اغتيال القيادات الاخرى من سرايا
القدس ابتداء بالثلاثه
الكبار الذين اغتالتهم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وابتدات باغتيالهم هذه الموجه
من التصعيد وحتى خلال ايام التصعيد في
اليوم الثاني عندما اغتالت علي غالي واحمد
ابو دقه في منطقه خان يونس كمسؤولين عن
الوحده الصاروخيه في في سرايا القدس وبال
تالي كما ذكرت هل هي المره الاولى
التي تكون فيها كذلك منذ بدايه هذه
العمليات قبل خمسه ايام
هي ليس كذلك حقيقه على العكس راينا هذه
الفترات كثيرا بعد كل عمليه اغتيال تقريبا
نشاهد فترات من هذا الهدوء النسبي والحذر
ومع استمرار رشقات متباعده وبين الفينه
والاخرى وفي المقابل ايضا سياسه الغارات
هي نفس الموضوع واكاد يتكرر هذا السيناريو
الان